all right how's it going reject nation
patronage X depending on where you're
watching this I'm John Humphrey of the
real rejects and I hey Greg is in
Colorado but you know what the show must
go on wanted to discuss the movie news
so I thought who better to bring on than
my man Kyle forget a fan Theory Channel
dot-com right I didn't screw you thought
you've got it right all right and yeah
so we're just going to talk about a few
of the top news stories of the week
there are going to be more of these over
on patreon but you know how the first
story we're going to talk about today
obi-wan Kenobi standalone film is
finally in the works Kyle I think this
is great and I think it makes perfect
sense yeah yeah okay and they said it
talks are in the quote earliest stages
there's no script but they are looking
at Stephen Daldry to direct this the
mastermind behind such films as Billy
Elliot and the hours so get ready for a
gripping obi-wan Kenobi drama I actually
think that's a very good choice yeah
yeah that's actually I'm in I'm
intrigued but as much as I'm ribbing
right now I'm intrigued by that choice
and they've also there's speculation
about whether or not you and McGregor
will return they've already used his
voice in the force awakens and whatnot
and he's been quoted as saying he'd very
much like to do it he said I'd very much
like to do one too I think the story
between Episode three and four I think
there's a story there um anything else
about this yeah and this is it one of a
number of rumored you know solo movies
there they're talking about making
they're working on Han Solo right now
there's also whispers of a Yoda and
above Fett movie but obi-wan and and I
think I think that is why they're
driving into the world of Obi one now
because I think they weren't sure how to
address it initially so they kept
putting it off but I think because of
what happened with the unsolo production
I think there and they really wanted to
release a new Star Wars film every year
and now they are not going to that's
okay with me that's that's okay I like
to miss stuff I like to be like oh that
thing I love I don't want to just expect
that it'll be
a year because leg is not as button you
want you want your heart to grow fondly
exactly yeah I don't know all my
favorite bands take like four years to
make a rash yeah to know like there's
nothing wrong with mixing it up and not
having the same thing every single year
yeah thank you sign at any time or the
thing is you know I don't know how these
spin-offs are going to shape up I did
like rogue one a lot which isn't about a
specific character but it is about a
very important event a very important
event and I like the way they change the
tone of that movie quite a bit you know
I love the war movie angle and hearing
that they're looking at Steven Daldry
for this does make me interested because
well he's more character based exact
which is really what we need more than
this is Star Wars to be even stood you
up then it can't just be you know if it
isn't a Michael Baker - yeah you know
Michael Bay Yes Doctor
the problem is I feel like there is an
alternate universe somewhere where
that's a thing and I kind of I don't
want to see it for real but like I wish
I could dream like a trainwreck kind of
thing you just can't you kind of wish
you could see it and yeah why did I see
it like once they leaked that fake
Michael Bay Batman script they're like
the first five pages of Michael Bay's
Batman he's hilarious and I would love
to see a Star Wars version of that but
um yeah I mean I'm not the world's
biggest star Wars fan but in terms of
their solos spin-off movies you know I'm
not really excited about the prospect of
a Yoda movie to be on No you know not at
all I think a han Solo movie could be
cool but I think it's a tall order
because again this is a big thing for me
I know I harp on this a lot but I feel
like certain characters are tied to the
actor who played them you know it's like
the remake of I always harp on Point
Break but if we're going to remake a
Point Break nobody seemed to care that
much because the heart and soul of that
movie is also Keanu Reeves and Patrick
Swayze and Lori petti and like those
people you know ob1 like Alec Guinness
is you know legend they're like that's
that definitive however Ewan McGregor
was able to step into those shoes and so
I don't feel like this is impossible
yeah you know and I feel like obi-wan is
actually a character that could be
interesting to explore and I think owes
off you know I I think that obi-wan I
think that Star Wars is one of those few
franchises where it is important to have
I mean this should always have good
character but I'm just saying in terms
of what the franchise is Star Wars
really kind of varied between those two
of character-driven
and blockbuster yes and so because of
that that's why I'm so excited about the
director that they've chosen and that's
exactly why I don't understand why Yoda
is even something that they're
considering doing because it's just
that's not there's nothing
why yeah I'm like I get what they're
doing I get they want to expand I don't
think what they're I don't think their
idea is a bad one to start doing these
cannot explore I would be okay with a
Yoda storyline that existed in like an
animated movie or something like that
because it's already an animated
character
yes isn't liven oh if I want to see Yoda
origin the movie no you know no but you
know like Boba Fett sounds I feel like
yeah I'm most satisfied the idea of
taking side characters or smaller
characters that are less iconic and less
you know central because we've gotten to
know those characters pretty well I feel
like obi-wan a--
i think there is some stuff you can do
with that i think there's some areas you
can explore yeah and if they really let
Steven Daldry bring his set of skills to
that I think it could be another
sophisticated entry into the movie
because especially if they want into the
series because if they want to do one a
year they've got to be different like I
feel like that's what we've learned from
the superhero boom is it helps you to be
stylistically broad you know I agree
100% yeah an Obi one I mean there's so
much story there to begin with so I
think they could tell what brought him
to the apprentice position in the
prequels like prior to that and they
could tell that story and tell it good
if they have Steven adulterer behind it
are you excited I mean would you want
Ewan McGregor to jump back in
um I mean yes and no I really dependent
on Holland right oh really
perfect I would I would have something
yeah Aston was everything he's like the
newest guys um I I mean yeah I think it
would be okay to have an integrator as
long as it didn't feel like we're doing
the pre-cool as long as it's more in the
vein of what the force awakens was or me
actually what rogue one was yeah like if
we kind of get that kind of feel for a
movie then yeah I don't care really who
plays we've been ruined McGregor who
plays obi-wan because it's it's probably
going to be a good film yeah and that's
really what matters so yeah I'm not
opposed to in McGregor I just it really
depends on how it's being delivered he
is in an interesting position because
they have at least a little bit embraced
him even though he is prominently a part
of most people least favorite things
about this year but he is also he's
owned before any better everything goes
moving yeah he's a pretty terrific actor
and yeah and as an obi-wan Kenobi I
think he's a good choice you know or it
was like back then one of the things
that worked for me in the prequels
anyway even if I did love how all that
transpire it's the like tis and you've
got a you know face that doesn't seem to
age much severer there's so he could do
it he could do it yeah here's some good
news patty Jenkins is in final talks to
win a storage directing deal for Wonder
Woman - yes this is going to be
fantastic yeah I mean why not continue
with the same person who won you over in
the first place yeah yeah no she's um
yeah I don't know if nobody knows
exactly what what the deal is but
according to Deadline the quote says
this typically according to sources a
frosh director on a-come Wow so long
times never really like a frosh
shorthand for freshmen and that was like
a whole I was like a whole epithet in
high school it's crazy a frosh director
on a comic book movie gets 1.5 million
to 3 million while director in the realm
of Zack Snyder who is helming DC's
Justice League received 10 million
10% cash break-even for his second DC
film Man of Steel I'd usually pad out a
20% during pre-production 60% or the
little film numbers yes so apparently
patty Jenkins is just about confirmed
that's exciting now I mean I hope she
get paid a tremendous amount and firmly
for bringing you some goodwill to their
entire operations like I feel like you
should give her all the money I might
now agree I feel like Zacks I mean again
circumstances aside I feel like dudes
like Zack Snyder should maybe work a
little harder for the Paycheck act maybe
focus up a little harder um yeah I mean
I'm definitely excited to hear that
she's coming back man yeah and I think I
think this is the perfect time for for
us to really talk about gender equality
uh because it's not um what are you
talking about Kyle we live in a post
everything society where nobody is
offended and everyone is racist now is
the time now is the time for something
good to happen for a female director and
I think I think it would be silly not to
give this to her I mean it's all about
dude yeah that would be ridiculous if
they were like no I think we want to
change course if they did that I would
be like I I'm not going to watch you
guys ooh I don't think you care that
much about writing the course anyone but
yeah I mean I'm definitely happy not
only just for her because the movie was
good but yeah I mean like it's about
time that like this shouldn't be news
but it's about time like it's I'm glad
to see that she's going to be able to
carry it over and I'm excited to see
where they take the series from here
because it seemed like she brought a lot
to the film it seems like she helps to
represent the best outcomes of DC's more
creator driven approach because the
thing is like the DC you started out
with this idea of we want we don't want
the committee so much we want it to be
our creatives who guide it and that's
not been the vibe for a lot of these but
but you know Wonder Woman I definitely
felt that and the things that she said
she wanted to accomplish definitely
shown through and it would be
interesting if you know
if she actually takes whatever happens
in the Justice League and builds off of
that um you know just because I'm not
sure if she's just going to make it more
like storyline separate from that but I
mean at this point she's kind of someone
have to make it in the world where this
has happened to her already
like Diana Diana price this is her
prints this has already happened to her
so we're going to build off of that
and I think that would be interesting to
take what we've gotten from the original
Wonder Woman film and and still like
connected to the Justice League because
it and I have to I think it's love
mashing together things to see what
something original you can create from
that and I think that's why this is it
would be perfect for her to be the
director for many reasons beyond the
obvious well yeah as the cross so you
know all these movies now have bigger
universes at hand there are a lot of
crossovers and people you know at least
judging by the Marvel movies because
they're deeper into their opera and you
know they've overcome at least for me as
if you are a lot of awkwardness and have
started to make their crossover stuff
more natural and Justice League actually
was happening before Wonder Woman
originally I mean early they were
working on it originally so like the
story is still probably going to feel
pseudo disconnected from Wonder Woman
yeah whereas Wonder Woman - it's not
going to be that way
yeah well and in Wonder Woman though the
benefit I think from being most mostly a
period piece you know yeah because you
can cap what it should be it should be
just separated for that reason alone
well and and the thing is now this just
makes me wonder what the vibe is going
to be on the second movie because I feel
like we'll probably be present-day
that's the vibe I got yeah and the
bookends of the movie and I don't like
just just me of the fan I kind of wish
we could stay period you know we could
it doesn't even have to be you know
World War two it can be yeah somewhere
else in the path during the Cold War or
something like that but you know I I
would be great actually that would be
great like you still make it take place
of course after Wonder Woman but it
could be leading up to still more
leading
where that goes yeah I would be okay
with that I think going going in like
yes more more of a but a slightly
different period of course yeah yeah I'm
you have time to work within for that so
yeah well and it's also it's going to
have to dot like I feel like if they go
modern I don't know what this story
would be but I you know everybody the
vibe is everybody's going to reference
Winter Soldier
you know the jump from first vendor to
winter sold and and the thing is like I
know a lot of people don't love the
First Avenger but I like that movie
quite a bit in terms of the Marvel stuff
and part of it is because I just loved
the period piece yeah maybe get elements
of it you know I liked spending time
like I think superheroes are really cool
in that context and you know that's
where so many of them came from is comic
strips from that time and so you know
you know I feel that being honored you
know in a movie like Wonder Woman and so
you know but not nevertheless I mean we
all pretty much knew pet like barring
some kind of astronomically strange
circumstance we all knew patty Jenkins
was going to come back and I'm super
psyched to hear that she is and I mean
they say this is going to be the highest
payout for a female director ever hell
yet yeah absolutely especially in the
landscape of DC EU movies thus far you
deserve all that and more and now well
you know I just I hope we can see even
more female directors getting these
opportunities and you know for
characters that aren't you know they
don't all have to be Wonder Woman or
Supergirl like just more more more
female directors let's do it more more
there's no reason why we don't yeah yeah
I mean more female directors more
directors of color let's get everybody
it really just needs to be about whoever
is the most qualified and there's no
reason to to be like this man is more
qualified but it's just you know
whoever's got the best take man
absolutely and that was the thing like
hearing hearing her talk about the
character I was like yeah it just seems
like you had a great vision in you and
you wanted to do some honor you wanted
to honor some things that the people
like great like that I can totally see
why you earned this job so good for you
yeah and she should be paid more
absolutely definitely alright guys thank
you for watching you can subscribe to
the real rejects hit that notification
bell to get notified every time a review
or video is up more new movie news what
have you the Cuyler Minh on Twitter and
Instagram fan Theory Channel dot-com is
where you can find this man and his
cohorts talking theories man that's
right
theorizing speculating that says chattin
you can follow us on patreon as well
we've got some cool stuff over there we
also t-shirts in our Spreadshirt store
and be beautiful
stay healthy hydrate and stretch
sometimes it's good for your soul what
the